c'est un m non ma part est un mec que
j'aime énormément c'est pascal sauter
celui qui a incarné pendant des années
pascal le grand frère a révélé hier
qu'il était en grosse galère financière
gagne 441 euros par mois il nous a même
lancé un appel pour devenir chroniqueur
s'est fait chez jordan de luxe que vous
retrouverez d'ailleurs avec benjamin
castaldi vendredi et jordan de luxe qui
est sûre non-stop paypal regarder pascal
le grand frère
combien on gagne quand on sait le grand
frère c'est une primaire peu près
anglais bien gay d'italie franchement on
gagne sa vie
ouais le dire qu'on gagne bien sa vie ce
serait mentir oui mais tu gagnes combien
aujourd'hui sur 441 euros je crois que
jean luc tu gagnes 400 euros par mois
mais tu fais comment pour en sortir je
me débrouille voilà d'accord il faut
faire des prestations touche pas à mon
poste civil c'est un message pour toi
syrie si tu me regarde je suis
chroniqueur chez kpn fait bientôt
j'espère donc compter sur moi c'était a
besoin de moi je suis libre voilà c'est
embrasser un message que tu lui as tu
viens tu devrais faire quoi être autour
de la table autour de la table et
pourquoi pas mettre une action en place
l'action sportive
c'était un petit peu les chroniqueurs
sur sur des choses bien précis d'accord
les mettre au défi qu en fait il serait
le meilleur à ton avis autour de la
table mois
le frère pascal mon grand frère
c'est une idée qui m'intéresse mais le
fait pas venir même si le nom c'est pas
mal ces temps ci c'est peut-être vous
entraînez allons voir comment vous
évoluez toute l'année nous on est
d'accord allemands ont photographié des
bûches glacées
il me prend en charge et toutes les
semaines tous les mois alors on fait ça
voici mais moi j'aime bien faire gonfler
vos seins
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il écoute parties fines et passion en
général je suis désolé non messieurs
j'adore ce mec en plus rares donc casser
l'ambiance mais c'est vrai que ça fait
penser quand même à la précarité des
gens telecom et sfr dur c'est à dire
qu'il était sur toutes les télés en
prime time
ouais c'est que tout va à coup tout va
bien tout est beau tout est gentil bah
non en fait précarité dans un
intermittent l art super dur aujourd'hui
là il a à peine de quoi vivre dans le
sud je suis d'accord avec toi